>>> WELCOME BACK.
YOU KNOW CONTACT SPORTS HAVE
TAKEN A HIT DURING THE PANDEMIC,
BUT PARTICIPATION IN TENNIS WITH
PLAYERS ALREADY DISTANCED IS UP
MORE THAN 20% THIS YEAR.
EVEN I'M PLAYING.
IN GEORGIA, JESSI MITCHELL FOUND
ONE YOUNG PLAYER WHO'S SHARING
HER LOVE OF THE GAME.
>> LINDEN PATTERSON PREPARED FOR
HUR LAST YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
TENNIS PANDEMIC STYLE.
WORKING OUT AT HER HOME COURT
AND AT HOME.
>> THERE'S A COUPLE OF RACKETS
OUT HERE.
>> Reporter: THAT'S WHERE SHE
NOTICED MORE THAN TEN YEARS OF
HER YOUTH TENNIS CAREER PILING
UP.
>> I STARTED REALIZING THAT
OTHER PEOPLE WHO I PLAY WITH ALL
THE TIME MUST HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM OR SAME RACKETS SITTING
OUT.
>> Reporter: TURNS OUT SHE WAS
RIGHT, SO PATTERSON CREATED LOVE
ALL TENNIS, SERVING UP RACKETS
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
PATTERSON HAS DONATED MORE THAN
2,000 RACKETS WITH HELP FROM
FRIENDS AND THE U.S. TENNIS
ASSOCIATION.
>> NOW YOU'RE JUST COLLECTING
THEM ON THE ROAD TOO, HUH?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO NOW I CAN KILL TWO BIRDS WITH
ONE STONE.
I'M GOING AND PLAYING TENNIS AND
HOPEFULLY WORKING ON MY GAME AND
THEN AT THE SAME TIME BETWEEN
MATCHES I'M GOING AND PICKING UP
BOXES.
>> HI!
>> Reporter: WE MET UP WITH
PATTERSON NEAR ATLANTA AS SHE
DELIVERED HER LATEST BATCH TO
SPECIAL POPS TENNIS ORGANIZATION
FOR PLAYERS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
LIKE TESSA HARGREAVES.
>> IF IT WASN'T FOR HER, I
WOULDN'T KNOW WHERE I WOULD BE.
>> THIS ONE IS FOR YOU.
>> Reporter: THE USTA SAYS
NEARLY 3 MILLION NEW PLAYERS
TOOK UP THE GAME LAST YEAR.
SPECIAL POPS ORGANIZER JIM HAMM
SAYS THAT USUALLY DOES NOT
INCLUDE MANY PLAYERS LIKE HIS.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN AROUND TENNIS
COURTS, BUT VERY FEW HAVE EVER
HAD THE CHANCE TO BE INVITED TO
BE ON THE TENNIS COURT.
>> Reporter: FOR 18-YEAR-OLD
HARGREAVES, TENNIS US MUCH MORE
THAN A GAME.
IT'S AN ESCAPE FROM THE
PANDEMIC.
>> IT HELPS ME EXPRESS MY
FEELINGS AND HELPS ME GET THE
CRAZINESS OFF MY MIND WITH WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
>> Reporter: THE IMPACT IS
OBVIOUS FOR THESE PLAYERS.
THE REAL CHANGE HAPPENED INSIDE
PATTERSON.
>> I CAME OUT EVERY DAY AND HIT
TENNIS BALLS AND DON'T THINK
TWICE ABOUT IT.
HERE THEY ARE AND THAT'S MAYBE
MADE THEIR WEEK, THEIR MONTH.
>> Reporter: PATTERSON PLANS TO
PURSUE HER PASSION AT COLLEGE
NEXT YEAR WITH A NEWFOUND
PURPOSE.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING SATURDAY,"
JESSI MITCHELL, MARIETTA,
GEORGIA.
>> LOOK, I THINK WHETHER IT'S
TENNIS, RUNNING, CYCLING, GET
OUT THERE, ENJOY YOURSELVES AND
CLEAR YOUR MINDS.
>> SO IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
DEALT WITH OVER THE LAST YEAR.
>> AND SUCH A GRE